Before we start talking about the Slavic migration
in to Balkans during the 5th and 6th century
we have to look at the area prior to their
arrival.
Most of the Balkans have always been kind
of poorly settled due to its mountains and
thick forests.
The cities and towns that did exist where
either by major in land routes or the sea.
The towns below this line were largely greek
where as the towns above it had more mixed
population.
For example the towns near the see where very
much Latin as oppose to the towns which were
more inland.
These probably still spoke Latin as it was
the mane trading language in the area but
they were mostly made up of Illyrian, Thracian,
Dacian and the remnants of some Germanic tribes.
However when the area came under the control
of the Byzantines even the northern cities
started to get more hellenized.
Now that we covered the cities let's look
at the countryside, what little of it was
populated, was mostly either by the descendants
of retired Roman soldiers which often times
at the end of their service where given land
in the Balkan region and or Illyrians, thracians,
Dacians, greeks and again some remnantses
of Germanic tribes (Gepids, Goths, OstroGoths
etc.).
And even though this may seem like a lot of
people, numbers wise it truly wasn’t.
There was also no clear predominant division
between these farming settlements, it would
be completely common to find a valley with
illyrian farmers next to a valley of Germanic
farmers next to two more valleys that were
not settled.
It is also reasonable to assume that all these
people intermingled in one way or another,
creating a small but diverse population.
Furthermore the reason why the Balkans were
so poorly settled and had a low economic development
was because of its Geography.
As mentioned before due to its mountains and
forested nature of the area and its location
right next to the Pannonian plain meant that
many nomadic tribes could easily raid in to
the region and then quickly retreat before
any kind of defence could be mounted as it
took a long time to transport troops in the
region.
Now that we have a small understanding of
the area let’s look at the Slavic migration
in to the Balkans.
Prior to their maine arrival in the 6th century
the Balkans suffered major raids from Germanic
and Hunnic tribes.
We have written records stating that small
towns where abandoned roads were destroyed
and the large chunk of the population fled.
The remaining people in the area lived in
sizeable fortified towns which were mostly
left alone during the raids.
It is possible that some Slavs came to the
Balkans with these Germanic and Hunnic tribes
as early as the 3rd century but even with
that it would be a very small percentage.
The main wave of the slavs came during the
6th century continuing in to the 7th.
The migration went either through the Lower
Danube Region however due to a more direct
Byzantine control of that area and the fact
it was more populated as it was largely spared
during the radingin period meant that this
wasn’t a popular spot of crossing for the
Slavs.
That is why the majority of the slavic tribes
went through the Moravian and Zemplin passes
in to the Pannonian basin and then into the
Balkans.
Now it is important to understand that this
slavic migration didn’t happen at ones.
It was more than a century long affair of
migration with intertwined larger and smaller
waves of settlers coming in to the region.
So why Didn’t the Byzantines stop the slavs?
Well there are multiple reasons why the Byzantine
didn’t protect the Balkans from the slavic
settlers even though it was under their control.
First it was because the slavs left the towns
and cities alone settling in the countryside
that wasn’t either populated in the first
place or was abandoned due to the raids.
This happened on a such a large scale that
Procopius and other writers mentioned that
the cities in the Balkans where like islands
in a slavic see.
So to the Byzantines there was nothing really
to protect since the slavs where taking up
area that was empty in the first place.
This also meant that some Byzantines were
happy with the slavs as they were rebuilding
and resetting the area that was destroyed
before.
Second reason why the Byzantense didn’t
stop the slavs was because during much of
the early slavic migration Justinian was busy
requiring italy.
And even if they had some free armies to fight
the slavs, Procopius writes that it was almost
impossible as if the “Byzantines defeated
or made a pact with one tribe, that arrangement
was valid for just one small group and had
no effect on any other tribe”.
This slavic disunity can be seen in the various
ways they settled the Balkans.
The first wave of the Slavs were “mostly”
peaceful settlers minding to their own business
but after them in the 560s Slavic tribes living
outside of the Byzantine empire held frequent
yearly raids that went as far as northern
Greece.
And since there where already some Slavs living
in the Balkans it was obviuse that many Slavic
tribes didn’t care much for each other fighting
between themselves as often as fighting against
others.
These yearly raids culminated during 570s
and 80s when the Avars came to central Europe
and started to solidify their rule over the
slavic tribes in the area.
As such the slavs that where still living
on the Border with the Byzantine Empire held
much larger raids in to the Balkans then before.
We have an account of one of these raids by
John of Ephesus but we know there where more
raids then just the one.
These raids were different then the ones prior
to this.
First because they were much larger involving
100k people and second after the radining
stopped instead of going back to the Avar
control territory the Slavs just stayed in
the Balkans.
The Avars not wanting to be left out from
all the radining also started to raid the
Balkans including the newly settled Slavs.
All of this was possible at the time because
the Byzantine army was fighting the Persians
in the East.
There where basically no soldiers left to
protect the Western Regions.
When the Persian war ended in 591, Emperor
Maurice finally could address the the Avar
and Slavic problem.
In the year 600 he managed to drove out the
Avars along with some of the Slavs but majority
of them have already settled in to a farming
life in the area.
At this point numbering hundreds of thousands
if not millions.
And even though the Byzantines tried the age
old Roman tactic of resettling tribes throughout
the empire sending some Slavs to Anatolia
and even the Caucuses it didn’t prove effective
as these where small numbers compared to the
actual Slavic population of the Balkans at
this point.
During the 7th century as the wars between
the Avars and Byzantines continued.
So did the constant flow of Slavic people
fleeing the Avar Khaganate and settling in
to the Balkans.
The North now being almost completely Slavic
and the South starting to get more and more
settlements.
There where even some accounts of Slavs trying
to raid and settle Greek Islands.
It was also during this time that many cities
and towns which held out like islands to Slavic
assimilations started to be slowly quote unquote
converted.
Now it is important to note that even though
some of these towns were military conquered
most of them were just peacefully assimilated
over time into the much larger Slavic population.
It is also important to recognise that during
this time there was lots of fighting and power
grabbing in the Balkans.
So even though the recognised area of Byzantine
control was this, there were lots of autonomous
areas some of which still saw themselves as
part of the Empire some which didn’t, some
of which were subdued by the Byzantines some
of which were not and then add the Avars for
even more complications.
So the Balkans where in this constant flux
of uncertain political control by various
groups.
But by far the Byzantines usually ended up
having the upper hand in the end.
The Balkans now almost completely settled
by the Slavs formed a dialect continuum.
This means that even though we are certain
the numerous slavic tribes had many different
dialects they still could understand each
other.
And even though this continuum still exist
in a different form to this day there are
clear differences from the one now to the
one in the early 7th century.
One of these changes to this continuum was
the arrival of the Croats and Serbs.
They arrived around the early to middle 7th
century to find numerous slavic tribes already
living in the Balkans.
Where the Croats and Serbs came from is very
much still debated.
We know for sure they came from the lands
north of the Danube as this is where all the
Slavs in the Balkans came from however the
specifics of why they decided to come to the
Balkans and how they manage to become so prominent
in a see of many different slavic tribes is
still largely unknown.
The likeliest origin is that the Serbs and
Croats just as many other slavic tribes where
under the Avar control going in to the 7th
century.
They then used the commotion and the Khaganate’s
instability during the Samo’s independence
war to migrate in to a more favorable area
in the Balkans.
This theory is supported by the fact that
the formation of Samo’s Kingdom correlates
with the dates of our presumed understanding
of Serbian and Croatian arrival in to the
Balkans.
It is also very much possible that this wasn’t
just a single one off migration by these two
groups and the trickle of Serbian and Croatian
people continued in to the 8th and 9th century.
Ones the two tribes established themselves
they quickly started influence the people
around them which can been seen today by the
fact that the people in the area speak a variation
of the Serbo-Croatian language.
Also during this time some of the people in
this area migrated North West in to today's
Slovenia.
Here they found western Slavic tribes from
Moravia which came to the area during the
first Slavic wave in the 6th century, however
more waves may have occurred all the way till
the fall of Samo’s Empire.
This mix of slavic tribes resulted in a unique
Slovenian culture and language which today
isn’t either western slavic nor Serbo-Croatian.
This area was at start controlled by the Byzantines
then conquered by the Avars and briefly vsaalized
by Samo’s Kingdom.
But when Samo died large part of the area
fell back to the Avars.
Nonetheless a small county Carantania manage
to remain independent partly due to the natural
mountains protection and partly due to the
Frankish influence in the area.
Then in 745 being threatened by the Avars
and most likely pressured by the Bavarians
the county first became part of Bavaria and
then annexed by the Carolingian Empire along
with the lands lost to the Avars after the
death of Samo.
During the 8th century Byzantines, Croats,
Serbs and Avars all had some sort of a political
power match within today’s Serbo-Croatian
area.
However due to unreliable and sparse written
records there’s nothing we can say for certain
about this area during this time.
It is most likely that during this struggle
the Serbs and Croats established some political
autonomy but the extend of that autonomy is
unknown.
Nevertheless we can presume that the Serbian
Vlastimirovic dynasty was established and
the precursors to the Croatian duchies of
Pannonia and Dalmatia may have started to
form shape.
Although this wouldn’t have been actual
duchies as feudalism still wasn’t in the
area.
They would have been more of a coalition of
tribes trying to fight for autonomy against
the Avars, Byzantine and other surrounding
tribes.
But while all of this was happening there
was another group which shaped south slavic
history and one we have more reliable sources
about.
The Bulgars where a coalition of nomadic Turkic
tribes originating somweher from Central Asia.
Over time this group also absorbed some Iranian,
Hunnic and other Indo-European people but
their lifestyle remained very much nomadic.
During the early 7th century they inhabited
the area of today’s Eastern Ukraine but
where under the control of the Avars.
That all started to change when the Avars
and Sassanids made an anti Byzantine alliance.
The Romans feeling threatened quickly started
to look for allies of their own.
They made friends with the powerful Bulgar
Dulo clan and as a sign of friendship the
clan send some of its children to the Byzantine
court.
One of these children was Kubrat who was said
to be a quick learner and had great admirations
for the Byzantines.
While at the Roman court Kubrat was said to
have converted to christianity before returning
back home.
Ones Kubrat returned he used what he learned
from the Romans and manage to unite the other
Bulgar tribes under one banner, promising
to free them from the Avars.
Then presumably during the Byzantine Sassanid
war when Avars where busy raiding the Balkans
Kubrat rebelled and won.
Quickly after this victory he solidified his
power and became the ruler of what we call
Great Bulgaria.
Continuing on Great Bulgaria and the Byzantines
had a close relationship and Kubrat’s reign
was very prosperous for the Bulgarian people.
He eventually died around 650s and 60s leaving
the kingdom to his sons.
With their distrust of each other combined
with the Kazar aggression the brothers divided
up the Kingdom and lead their people to settle
different areas within Europe.
One of these brothers Asparuh who traveled
along the Black Sea quickly came in to a dispute
with the Byzantines.
After a few battles the most decisive one
being the battle of Ongal he manage to win
and settle the area of Lower Danube in 681
which is regarded as the foundation year of
modern Bulgaria.
Few years later another brother of Asparuh,
Kuber who first went to the Pannonian plain
and became an Avar vassal rebelled and migrated
with his people to an area of modern day Macedonia.
Here after few battles he became a Byzantine
vassal around the end of 680s and this is
where all written records about Kuber and
his people end, presumably settling and assimilating
into the local population.
This population being overwhelmingly slavic.
In fact the slavic population in the lands
settled by the Bulgars was so numerous that
after just 2 centuries the Bulgar language
died off and what remains to this day is a
Bulgaro-Macedonian slavic language.
What the Bulgars manage to achieve in the
next 2 centuries is impressive and could easily
have its own video.
In a very brief way they established the First
Bulgar Empire and even though it had some
setbacks on occasion with some internal strife
they managed to expand in to much of Southeastern
Europe by the 9th century.
They accomplished this through carefully crafted
diplomatic actions, numerous military victories
and expansion in to the former Avar territory.
This meant that Bulgaria stretched from the
Black Sea to Pest from the Dniester to the
Ionian Sea.
But bulgaria had a problem.
It was still pagan in an increasingly Christianised
world.
Boris the 1st new that converting would result
in far better diplomatic relations but he
was already afraid of the increasing Byzantine
influence in his realm.
So his first idea was to convert to Roman
Catholicism rather than Eastern Orthodox.
However this brief flirt with Catholicism
didn’t last because in 864 Boris lost a
war with the Byzantines and in the peace treaty
agreed to convert to Eastern Orthodox along
with his people.
Naturally no one was happy as Boris didn’t
want the increase byzantine influence over
Bulgaria and the Bulgarian people didn’t
want to change from their pagan beliefs.
But Boris had a plan in mind.
He quickly suppressed the rebellious populace
and then invited the exiled disciples of Cyril
and Methodius which where no longer welcomed
in Moravia.
He then ordered them to translate the greek
church liturgy in to old Bulgarian using the
Glagolitic alphabet.
This way Boris could expel the Greek priests
and replace them with his own Bulgarian Priests
all while not breaking the treaty.
The clerics quickly got to work but Glagolitic
proved not ideal for old Bulgarian and so
the new Cyrillic alphabet based off of the
older glagolitic was created.
From there cyrillic quickly spread through
the Slavic orthodox lands replacing Glagolitic
as the mane slavic alphabet.
Although there were some continues remnantses
of the use of glagolitic all the way till
the 19th century mainly in Croatian church
services.
The Bulgarian golden age wouldn’t however
last forever.
First the Magyars arrived in the 10th century
threatening the Bulgarian borders.
Second the new powerful Kievan Rus started
to take much of Bulgarian trade and influence
and lastly the continues Byzantine hostilities
all culminated in the Bulgarian vasilization
by the Byzantines in the early 11th century.
Going back to the end of the 8th century in
the Serbo Croatian region we are starting
to get more sources which is correlated with
the arrival of the Franks and Christianity
in to the Region.
We learn of Viseslav of Serbia the first reliable
mention of a ruler of the serbian Vlastimirovic
dynasty starting in around 780 and was most
likely overseen in one way or another by the
Byzantines.
We also learn of Viseslav of Croatia or more
precisely Dalmacia who lived around the same
time and is most well known for his early
attempts of trying to convert Dalmacia to
Christianity and his eventual defeat at the
hands of the franks after which Croatian Dalmacia
became part of the Frankish Empire and Croatian
Panonia became a vassal.
So at the beginning of the 9th century the
area kind of looked like this, with the slavic
lands being ruled by Slavic rulers but overall
very much under the sphere of influence by
the two major powers.
At Least until Ljudevit became the duke of
Pannonia in 810.
He was raided by the Frankish duke of Friuli
and after the Emperor Louis the Pious decided
not to punish the duke, enraged Ljudevit rebelled
in 819.
He quickly started to recruit allies most
notably from the Slovenian Carantiania.
After making some initial gains the triple
armies of the Frankish king, The Duchy of
Friuli and the Croatian Dalmacia which was
now ruled by Borna the successor of Viseslav
of Dalmacia, proved to be overwhelming for
Ljudevit who lost in 822 and escaped to the
Serbian lands.
He was welcomed by the successor of Viseslav
of Serbia Radoslav but Ljudevit had different
plans.
He killed Radoslav and tried to take control
of Serbia.
What exactly happened after that we don’t
know but presumably it didn’t go well as
Ljudevit in 823 escaped to Croatian Dalmacia
now ruled by Ljudemisl.
But Ljudemisl just as his predecessors Borna
was loyal to the Franks and so he promptly
killed Ljudevit ending the Croatian rebelion.
With that the Frankish rule over Croatia was
solidified and the Croatian Serbian border
became the divide between the Frankish Sphere
of Influence and the Byzantine Sphere of influence.
Which can be kind seen today in the division
of religion and Alphabet in the Balkans.
Later on in Croatian Dalmacija Trpimir the
first who established the Trpimirovic dynasty
that ruled croatia until 1091 would also successfully
gain autonomy by playing the Byzantine and
Franks off of each other.
However the recognized autonomous kingdom
of Croatia wouldn’t be established until
the Dalmacijan annexation of Croatian Pannonia
in 924-25.
It was also during this time that the Catholic’s
church influence in the area solidified and
pagan practice over all ended in Croatia.
In Serbia on the other hand the succession
crisis caused by Ljudevit was quickly solved
by Vlastimir who consolidated his power in
Serbia around the 830s but still remained
under the influence of the Byzantines.
He was also faced with the problem of Bulgar
advancement towards the Serbian lands but
against all odds defended his realm supposedly
with no Byzantine help.
During the rest of his reign Vlastimir consolidated
his power and manage to gain Serbian independence
from the Byzantines.
How exactly he did that we have no written
sources about.
After his death in the late 840s his son started
a long succession war which was won by Mutimir.
Mutimir then went on to over see even more
successful campaigns against the Bulgars and
also the Christianization of the Country in
to the Eastern Orthodoxy.
And even though there’s countless of events
I could talk about going on from here or address
your comments of why I didn’t talk about
White Croatia or White Serbia which are just
foundation myths.
I will leave it off here.
With the Bulgars starting their golden age
and ruling over their Macedonian brothers,
the Serbs finally independent from the Byzantine
rule the Montenegrins partly under Byzantine
and Serbian control, Croatians free from Frankish
sphere of Influence, the Bosnians probably
being the last slavic tribe to get Incorporated
in to the Serbo-Croatian family group and
Slovenians well under the German control for
a long time.
This is not to say that all these lands were
just slavic at this point there were still
most likely some remnants of Roman, Illyrian,
German etc. settlements however compared to
the bigger political picture they were a small
spec in the Balkan Slavic Political Sphere.
Please consider Subscribing and supporting
me on Patreon as Youtube has still not renewed
my monetization for some reason and any financial
help would be appreciated.
I hope you enjoyed the video you can read
my full scripts with sources for free on Patreon
and as always there’s more historical information
and clarification in the description.
My name is M.Laser and please join me next
time when I will look at the early history
of Eastern Slavs.